spring is here and many of you are
getting ready to host friends and family
for Easter and all of us are thinking
about spring cleaning so we can deep
clean our homes and tackle the dirt dust
and pollens that trigger our Springtime
allergies well there is a solution
Zerorez and joining us to tell us more
our owners Ben and Doug McKee welcome
back you guys this is a messy carpet and
we're going to show you the zero res
difference in just a minute but I was
just talking to you guys about allergies
they're getting bad right now and zero
arrest can actually help with that we
can't eat you gotta understand Mercedes
your carpet at your home or at your
business is the largest air filter so
it's collecting all the dust pollen
dander and all those nasty things
floating around in the air and getting
your carpets professionally cleaned is a
great way to reset that filter so that
it not only looks good but it actually
goes back to filtering the air yeah if
you just are going with Aesthetics and
how it looks the zero resident
difference is amazing especially if you
are someone like me who has white carpet
when you guys come in it looks brand new
and it's all because of your Zero Water
tell us a little bit about that yeah so
our technology we clean carpets unlike
anybody else out there traditional
carpet cleaning methods are actually
detrimental to your carpet's health
they'll cause rapid resoiling and it's
because traditionally carpet cleaners
use soap zero res we don't leave any
soap residue behind we're not putting
any surfactants in your carpet you're
left with clean carpets like they came
from the factory let's see Zero resin
action and while we are watching I love
this this is my favorite part the one
swipe
French it's incredible you can see right
away the difference but you gotta
understand this is your water it acts
like a soap without any of the residue
left behind this water is heated up to
about 230 degrees at our truck mount
it's hooked up to a 300 horsepower
vacuum so we're deep fitting your
carpets and we're getting it nearly dry
when we're finished and you
again correct again yeah I lost kind of
how many years but it's because you know
we've been in Las Vegas for nearly 20
years Doug started us out of his garage
and we're just we're a family-owned
business and we want to make sure that
our customers have a great experience
and we're here to create raving fans and
get your home cleaned up I noticed that
the second someone comes into my home
from zero res always so nice respectful
but puts on the booties gets everything
done and it's so great now you guys
always have a special for us tell us
what you're going to give away we do
right now you can get your carpets
cleaned as low as 35 dollars per room
plus we're gonna throw in a hallway
absolutely free minimums apply but take
advantage of the deal absolutely thank
you again to zero rest look at that for
sponsoring this segment check out their
spring cleaning special of the month
carpets clean for as low as 35 dollars
per room plus get that hallway cleaned
free call
702-840-333 or go online
zerorezlasvegas.com for more minimum
Supply we'll be right back